hey what's up my name is samuel leeds
i'm a property investor i've been
investing in property now for 12 years
i've done over 300 property deals and
right now
on this video i'm going to be answering
your property investment questions
so any niggly property investment
questions that you have around mortgages
tax how to find deals how to structure a
deal do me a favor
comment it below comment your property
questions below on this video
and then i'm gonna do my very best to
answer your questions right now
we got pabushi i'm gonna read pabushi's
question
but before i even do that do me a big
favor as well smash the like button
subscribe to the channel and turn the
notification bell
on i mean how disappointing would it be
if you ask a question
below and then i comment and i respond
next week
but you don't see the video because you
weren't subscribed so subscribe
turn the bell on and let's get to this
so pabushi
how do you know when you're multi-let
whether you need a license eg selective
additional or mandatory
okay so generally speaking mandatory
licensing for hmos is when there's five
or more people in the property some
areas do have selective or additional
licensing so if
if a property has additional licensing
um
then that means that hmo might need a
license even if there's only three
people in it
if there's selective licensing in an
area it might be that all by to let's
need a license for instance wales i
think the whole of wales the selective
licensing
so i own properties in wales i've got to
have a license just to rent the property
out
so how do you find out the information
there's a very very special website you
can go to
i'll give you the website right now so
you might want to write this down it's
www
dot g o o
g l e google okay literally a lot of
stuff you can google
um you can't google certain things
because you're just gonna be
wrapped up in so much information like
if you say where's a good investment
area
you know google's going to come up with
all these silly blogs and articles
written by teenagers
but if you want to know about whether an
area has selective licensing mandatory
additional
google it you should get the government
website the local council website that
will come up and give you all the
information
that you need to know that's helpful
next question we got paul
omartosi paul says great content samuel
keep it up
do you think artificial intelligence
will affect how we invest in buy to let
in the future thanks
um will artificial intelligence i think
artificial intelligence is going to
affect
just about everything it is going to
affect if anyone doesn't know what
artificial intelligence is
um it's basically like digital online
systemization of things um i'm not an
expert in artificial intelligence i'm an
expert in property
but in my in my opinion people complain
about artificial intelligence because
they say it's gonna make people
redundant it's gonna lose jobs
but if if people can be replaced
by a system a robot a computer
in my opinion that's only a good thing
because it means that
even though it might be making someone's
job redundant it's also going to be
making things easier
and convenient and it's going to be also
opening up other opportunities
people generally don't like change i
like change um
so i'm excited to see artificial
intelligence make things better and
quicker and systemized
in property i mean the so far the only
things that i've really seen changing in
property
um is it's just making things easier
with tenants you know
systems and and things and checks and
so i i don't think it's gonna make
property buy to let bad i mean geez
you're always going to need somewhere to
live
no matter how many robots there are geez
maybe i'll rent my house out to one of
the robots
and get double rent i don't know i i'm
not too concerned
i think it's an exciting thing if i've
got a property and i own bricks and
mortar
someone has to live in that house
artificial intelligence might make their
payments to me slicker
simpler you know the checks epc checks
everything all systemized and automate
that's a good thing
but they're still going to need to pay
rent and that rent is going to go to me
because i own the monopoly board right
so that's generally my view and how i
feel be interested in your thoughts and
comments though if you have any
differing opinions comment below because
i'm still learning okay
bailey parsons thoughts on selling a
property through express
offers today express offers today
they're a little bit like
we buy any car but for houses they'll
offer you a cheap offer if you're
desperate and you need the cash quick
maybe it's worth a look-see however if
you're desperate you need the money
quick i'd also suggest that you speak to
mr samuel leeds
if you're prepared to sell your house
for 75 market value
give me drop me a message uh there's
also i don't know if you're talking
about the
there's an as an estate agent as well
called express estate agency
i've bought through them many times i've
never sold my house through express
office today i have bought through
express estate agency they're pretty
good they'll market the property cheap
but they'll put offers over
um so yeah that's all i have to say
declan hume what are the options for
someone that is working on a zero hour
contract and wants to start investing
into
property great video sub thank you for
subscribing declan if you're on a zero
hour contract and you want to invest in
property
um it depends what you want to do i mean
my advice probably wouldn't be massively
different to you than anybody
if you can if you're going to try and
get a mortgage
and you're on zero hours you might even
be surprised
because brokers care more about the
property than they care about you so
um zero hour contract
i suggest you definitely need to get
into property because you need some you
need some guaranteed income
maybe start deal sourcing get some money
coming in find an investment joint
venture on it
i don't think i don't think you the fact
that you're on zero hours makes
would mean that suddenly all my systems
and techniques are different for you
than for the next person
richard j mitchell love your videos
thank you for the time you spend with us
quick question i'm looking to buy a few
buy to let's i understand it's better in
a limited company is you can deduct the
mortgage costs
that is correct but do you have to pay
tax if you're making a small amount
example only one house might make six
thousand pounds a year profit
any tax on that small amount or is there
a minimum starting value before paying
tax
yeah so um richard i'm not an accountant
so i can't give tax advice
but i am experienced and um
you won't pay tax on the first 11 000
pounds i think it's 11 000 pounds you'll
pay
no tax at all and then thereafter
there'll be a sliding scale
if you're buying through a company you
want to pay yourself a dividend
so you want to pay yourself a salary of
11 grand
and then you won't pay tax on that and
then any uh more income that you want to
take out
you're going to take out a dividend and
i think it's up to around 40 000 pounds
where you're only gonna pay about seven
and a half percent on your money
and then after that when you start you
know getting bigger and bigger the tax
is gonna
the scale will slide and that's why i
mean there's a whole bunch of stuff i
could say about tax and saving money on
tax
um but but i hope that answers your
question for now
thanks so much richard walsh
hi samuel i purchased my residential
home for a hundred and eighty thousand
pounds and spent fifty thousand on it
and now the new value is
290. boom shaka so you made like
60 000 pounds equity uplift profit very
very cool i now want to refinance to set
up a limited company and do brr the
question is
will they limit the amount i can pull
out as i'm a single person on an
average salary if you're living in the
house
yes if it's your residence
they are going to limit they are going
to limit how much they'll give you um
i don't know what the exact ratio is but
because you're living
in the property if they if they lend you
a load of money against the house
they're going to want to know how you're
going to pay it back
because you're going to have to pay it
from your pocket if the property is a
buy to let property and you're renting
it out
they care more about the affordability
of the property based on the tenants and
the rents does the deal stack
that about you however
speak to a mortgage broker and and see
what they say also maybe maybe worth
selling the house
you bought it for 180 it's now worth 290
if you sell it
you won't pay any tax on that because
you don't pay capital gains tax if you
lived in the property and then you can
use the profits to then
reinvest the world is your oyster my
friend richard keep up the good work i
hope that helps
gonzalez hi is it possible to rent out a
three bed flat
use one bedroom yourself and rent out
the other two so you barely pay any rent
it's like house hacking but we've rent
would that be possible or is it
considered rent to rent and you need
some type of
contract thanks so much yep that is very
possible indeed in fact people do this
all the time as long as you have
permission
from the landlord to do it and you're up
front yes
you can do that it's a very smart
strategy where you can live
rent free very similar to rent to rent
but you're living there yourself it's
actually really really
slick so house hocking house hacking in
real life boom shaq and go do it daniel
roberts piano
samuel what time does the crash course
start i'm in brazil so i know it'll be
very early
um oh i don't know it depends on the
time zone that you're in uk time
it starts around about 9 30 and the
crash courses are through the roof
last time we ran a crash course we had i
think it was about 22 countries
represented we had people from all over
the world it was an online virtual crash
course
live people from america that were
finding deals in their in their home
towns in their states from america using
the principles
a lot of deals a lot of money made see
you there and uh
even if it's in the middle of the night
it's worth it faster freedom
great one i have done over 150 deals
like this and this is a great video oh
thank you so much 150 deals
dude you need to be on winners on a
wednesday or something great to see so
many people actually doing deals in the
comments i'm pumped
um delashan anthony paul hi samuel do
you think two thousand pounds is enough
for you to get your first rent to rent
deal
i would say yes i always say that it is
rent to rent when you're negotiating
rental rents with the landlord you're
going to try and put down as little
money as possible
if you find a property that's already
furnished
and you can negotiate to not pay a
deposit because you can say to the
landlord look
i'm going to be giving you a guaranteed
rent i'm going to be taking deposit off
the tenants
so you can agree no deposit and
some upfront uh a rent-free period for
the first few weeks
i mean that's probably pushing a little
bit but potentially you could put down
next to nothing so i think two thousand
pounds
generally speaking is about minimum uh
that you're gonna need it also depends
on where you are in the country
but yeah i think that's enough to
probably get you started all right last
one
tyrone saxton what's happening bro good
to see you in the comments again
um he says hi samuel what areas have you
been in or purchased the property in
northampton do you know the area well
be good to meet you one day i got your
book for christmas as a present and
really enjoyed it read it in four days
when i eventually meet you i'll have a
heart attack with shot peace out
hey tyrone appreciate you man um
northampton i don't know northampton
super well i don't live a million miles
away from northampton i live in
buckinghamshire
um a lot of my students are doing deals
are in and around northampton area
though
corby i think that's northamptonshire uh
i know alistair has got a property deal
that he's doing at the moment in bedford
which is which is working really well
juicy juicy deal
um so i think northampton is a great
area i know you've got you've got at
least one hmm i'm aware of
uh in northampton so um i think it's a
good area
i reckon you should make northampton
your patch you should
dominate northampton make northampton
into your little [ __ ] that's what i
reckon
anyway folks hope you enjoyed this q a
sunday if you did
smash the like button drop your
questions and comments below in the in
the in the comment box
i'll be answering more questions next
sunday subscribe
and i'll see you all soon peace out
[Music]
you